hey 42 here oh hi Oh state university
offers a course called sports for the
spectator students are taught how to be
informed and appreciative sport
spectators welcome to RIF 70% of all
train journeys in England start or
finish in London swinging your arms
whilst walking makes it 12% easier
travelling at normal speed it takes a
fully-loaded supertanker
20 minutes to stop they usually cut
their engines about 15 miles away from
the dock
research shows that plants grow better
when they're stroked the record number
of live goldfish swallowed as a single
sitting is 210 Frank Sinatra took a
shower 12 times a day before the
invention of electricity human beings
slept for 90 minutes longer than they do
now the fastest swallow in nature is
that of the frog fish which sucks its
prey down in 0.006 seconds at its peak
Blockbuster Video earns nearly 800
million dollars through late fees alone
making up 16 percent of its revenue the
first baseball caps were made of straw
the ancient Egyptians mummified beef
ribs sliced dog and goat meat to eat in
the afterlife Mozart's sister was also a
musician who sometimes took the top
billing as they toured around Europe to
get the most leaves ever found on a
single clover is 12
statistically too much homework can
cause depression and lower grades
getting angry at people when listening
to them breathing or eating is an actual
neurological disorder called misophonia
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2